let's talk money real quick this is a
you know a financial show at the end of
the day that we do cover 11 topics so
you know your last job was teaching then
you turned to videography now you're
making money on youtube yeah so how do
you make money on youtube what advice do
you have for
content creators and then when you're
making the money what have you learned
about managing your money what's the
best financial lesson you've learned 100
to me to make money on youtube
you got to do it for at least five years
and that's the part nobody wants to
listen to is there an exception to the
rule where you do a video and it goes
viral sure it's one video though a
hundred percent you have to be so
consistent i love patrick but david's
i'll improve i'll innovate out
strategize outlast the competition
so when you're the content creators who
are really making money my advice to you
is go to their videos and go to oldest
videos
yeah nine years 12 years 11 years 10
years they've been at it for a minute if
it was easy everyone would do it it was
easy everyone would do it so to me it's
a question of can you consistently each
week
for five years in a row put out videos
that's the first question you got to ask
yourself
when we started a lot of people started
with us
nobody's there with nobody else who
started with is also doing content so as
a man as a creator you have to be
consistently doing this for at least
five minutes you've only been doing it
three years
youtube
okay youtube youtube yeah you're right
we've been to youtube for three and a
half four years
so you're even acknowledging look i'm
not even where i need to go right now
it's not of course not yeah of course
not am i even close but this is what you
do full time yeah yeah i'm not even
close and then you also have to have
radical accountability
and ask yourself if i'm not getting the
views i want is it because i'm not good
mm-hmm
like what am i doing wrong with you yeah
content yeah because to me it's like if
you're not if you're if you're always
getting cut by your high school
basketball team
it might be your coach as a dick yeah it
might be there's a superstar
team where you would have been a
superstar on another team but it might
be you're just not good in basketball
[Music]
you